[Musique]
ghislaine et patrice ont signé un bail
de douze mois il des ménages dans le
logement de leurs rêves
six mois plus tard rien ne va plus ils
se séparent et ne veulent plus habitée
de logements il croit pouvoir rompre
leur bail avec un avis de trois mois
erreur c'est un mythe vient dans la loi
ne donne le droit à un locataire de
payer trois mois de loyer pour résilier
son bail en or un locataire ne peut pas
résilié son bail n'importe quand pour
n'importe quel motif
mais il ya des exceptions par exemple un
locataire qui se voit attribuer un
logement à loyer modique peut résilier
son bail mais séparation n'est pas une
de ces exceptions que peuvent faire
quillan et patrice alors ils peuvent
tenter de conclure une entente avec le
propriétaire un défaut d'une entente est
obsédé leur bail ou sous louer leur
logement
mais dans les deux cas il faut le
consentement du propriétaire le fin mot
de l'histoire
on ne résilie pas un bail pour une
chicane dans sa cabane